it now appears that flight mh370 s
disappearance may have been deliberate
Malaysia's Prime Minister says
investigators believe that communication
systems were manually disabled by
someone on the flight but he wouldn't
confirm going suspicions that it was
hijacked after its transponder was shut
off the aircraft apparently left its
planned flight path its last satellite
contact suggests two possible flight
corridors but they're enormous Northern
Corridor stretching approximately from
the border of Kazakhstan and
Turkmenistan to northern Thailand all a
Southern Corridor stretching
approximately from Indonesia to southern
Indian Ocean since the hijacking is now
seen as a real possibility the
passengers and crew have come under
renewed scrutiny on Saturday police
searched the homes of the pilot and
co-pilot in Kuala Lumpur where they
reportedly spent several hours for the
families of the 239 people on board the
missing aircraft it's a new turn of
events
should end up off on the what now that
we're getting more accurate information
I feel there is brighter hope in finding
the plane as well as the passengers of
the plane fun a little fun the search
continues for now it's focusing on the
Indian Ocean